Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
La storia che vi sto per raccontare
è una storia molto personale,
diciamo proprio una storia autobiografica,
che è in fondo, in un certo senso,
la storia della mia famiglia.
In generale, però, potrebbe essere
anche quella delle vostre
e in assoluto, un pochino,
la storia del nostro essere umani.
Le protagoniste della mia storia
sono queste due signore di spalle:
quella a destra è mia mamma, 81 anni;
quella di sinistra,
mia figlia, ne ha sette
ma a volte, per quello che dice,
sembra che ne abbia anche più di 81.
E un giorno, la bimba mi ha chiesto:
"Papi, ma noi da dove veniamo?".
Il caso vuole che fossimo di ritorno,
un anno fa più o meno, da un viaggio,
e ci trovavamo all'aeroporto
internazionale di Addis Abeba
che è il più importante crocevia
del traffico aereo africano oggi.
Addis Abeba ha una particolarità:
è il luogo dove, al Museo Nazionale,
c'è l'esemplare del nostro
antenato forse più antico,
di quello che potrebbe essere uno
dei nostri antenati diretti
più antichi ad aver avuto
una postura bipede:
questa è Lucy,
un esemplare di australopiteco
scoperto nel 1974
da un paleoantropologo, Donald Johansson,
e dai suoi collaboratori,
che risale a 3,2 milioni di anni fa.
E negli anni, scoprendo altri reperti
di questo nostro lontanissimo antenato,
abbiamo scoperto che era probabilmente
uno dei primi a camminare su due zampe.
Però, la nostra storia comincia
da un periodo un pochino più recente.
In realtà, altro colpo
di fortuna se si vuole,
fortuna vuole appunto
che io qualche anno fa,
abbia partecipato
al progetto "Genographics"
della National Geographic Society.
In che cosa consiste
il progetto "Genographics"?
In un tentativo di ricostruire
la mappa delle migrazioni umane,
attraverso l'analisi del DNA,
di quante più persone possibile:
a oggi, hanno partecipato
circa 800.000 persone.
In che cosa consiste?
Si manda un campione
della propria saliva fino a Washington.
Lì viene analizzato, e attraverso
750.000 marcatori sul nostro DNA
si cerca di risalire alle variazioni,
alle mutazioni del DNA
che hanno fatto sì
che si differenziassero,
nei 70.000 anni in cui Homo Sapiens
ha colonizzato il mondo,
le diverse popolazioni umane.
Attraverso il lavoro del Genographic,
oggi si è ricostruita questa mappa
che in realtà porta dalla zona
da cui è partito Homo Sapiens,
quasi 70.000 anni fa,
che è proprio la zona,
non proprio magari
quella esattamente di Addis Abeba,
ma nel Corno d'Africa, da queste parti,
dove Homo Sapiens ha cominciato
a migrare verso nord,
e nel giro di più di 50.000 anni
arrivare a colonizzare, anche,
l'estremità meridionale delle Americhe.
Ci sono voluti 50.000 anni
perché occupassimo tutto il mondo.
Attraverso il Genographic,
è stato possibile ricostruire:
da una parte la mia linea paterna,
quella che ereditiamo sempre
per parte di padre,
per cui purtroppo le signore
non lo possono fare.
La linea paterna,
quella che realizziamo,
per parte di padre,
attraverso il cromosoma y,
che hanno soltanto i maschi.
Dall'altra parte,
attraverso il DNA mitocondriale,
che ereditiamo soltanto dalla madre,
è stata ricostruita la storia
di quella signora
che vi facevo vedere prima.
La storia che comincia qui, per l'appunto,
circa 67.000 anni fa in Africa Centrale,
quando Homo Sapiens moderno
comincia a migrare da questa regione.
E intorno a 60.000 anni fa,
si trova ad attraversare
la penisola del Sinai,
dove un gruppo di queste popolazioni,
individuato proprio attraverso
questi marcatori genetici,
si sposta attraverso la penisola del Sinai
e comincia a passare in parte
nella penisola arabica, nel Medio Oriente,
e a spostarsi: un pochino
verso l'Anatolia, in Turchia,
un po' verso nord, nel Caucaso,
e in parte verso l'Asia, a est.
Poco più avanti,
i discendenti di questo gruppo
continuano a spostarsi,
in parte di nuovo verso nord
e ancora verso est:
siamo a 55.000 anni fa, circa.
E intorno a 40.000 anni fa,
si differenzia un'altra popolazione,
che è quella che, da una parte,
prende direttamente
la strada della Turchia
per arrivare in Europa.
E dall'altra, invece,
fa la strada più lunga,
attraversa il Caucaso
e comincia a colonizzare
la parte settentrionale dell'Europa.
Che cosa succede?
Che 20.000 anni fa,
con l'arrivo della glaciazione,
quelli che avevano colonizzato
la parte settentrionale dell'Europa
si spostano un pochino verso sud,
e cominciano a colonizzare
regioni più miti:
l'Italia, la Spagna e allo stesso tempo
anche l'Inghilterra,
che ha un clima sicuramente più mite
del resto del nord Europa.
Che cosa succede, la storia è finita qui?
No, la storia di fatto
la rivediamo a ritroso,
perché attraverso
tutta questa serie di passaggi
che definiscono la migrazione
di tutta la mia linea materna,
abbiamo superato una serie di punti
che sono fondamentali,
o comunque che sono cruciali:
anche questi, un po' di colpi di fortuna.
Per immaginare come siamo arrivati
fino a noi, in Pianura Padana -
io sono milanese -
partendo da un luogo sperduto
nel continente africano, 70.000 anni fa.
Uno dei primi posti,
se ricominciamo a ripercorrere
questa strada a ritroso
dove siamo passati,
è più o meno quell'area
al confine tra l'Italia e l'Austria
dove c'è il ghiacciaio del Similaun,
dove qualche anno fa
è stato scoperto Ötzi,
l'uomo dei ghiacci, ice man,
come lo volete chiamare.
Questa figura mummificata,
perfettamente mantenuta
per più di 5.000 anni
all'interno dei ghiacciai alpini,
e che, con il disgelo dei ghiacciai,
è riapparsa alla superficie.
E di cui abbiamo avuto
talmente tante testimonianze
da poter immaginare come vivessero
i nostri predecessori europei
circa 5.000 anni fa.
Quest'uomo si sa che è morto
in circostanze bizzarre:
è stato verificato che aveva
una punta di freccia
conficcata nella spalla sinistra,
e che probabilmente
ha causato il decesso;
però si sono trovate
le armi che usava per cacciare,
gli abiti, tutto quanto,
per cui siamo riusciti in qualche modo
a ricostruire l'idea
che i nostri antenati
di qualche migliaio di anni fa
facessero una durissima vita,
tra la pianura, le colline
e le montagne dell'Italia settentrionale.
E che fossero, soprattutto,
ancora grandi cacciatori.
Se risaliamo un pochino più a nord,
ci ritroviamo in questa zona
qua della Germania,
a Lipsia per la precisione,
al Max Planck Institut
per l'antropologia evolutiva.
Qui c'è questo signore,
che si chiama Svante Pebo,
e che è uno dei più grandi studiosi
di genetica delle popolazioni
attraverso l'analisi del DNA.
Quello che ha in mano
è un calco di un cranio di Neanderthal,
perché lui ha sequenziato,
attraverso i pochi resti
di cui disponiamo,
il genoma dell'uomo di Neanderthal.
Per scoprire una cosa fondamentale,
che mi sono ritrovato tranquillamente
nella mia linea materna.
È il fatto che una parte
del nostro genoma di europei
lo abbiamo ereditato
dall'Uomo di Neanderthal,
mediamente il 2,1%.
Il mio DNA è al 2% neandertaliano
nel periodo in cui i Neanderthal
hanno convissuto con Homo Sapiens,
più o meno tra 60.000 e 40.000 anni fa,
quando i Neanderthal sono scomparsi.
Homo Sapiens e uomo di Neanderthal
si sono incrociati, ma non basta:
pare che Homo Sapiens si sia incrociato
anche con un altro ominide
abbastanza bizzarro -
perché non ne sappiamo nulla,
abbiamo fatto solo una scoperta
in una grotta delle montagne dell'Altai,
tra Russia e Cina.
Questo Uomo di Denisova,
di cui è stato però possibile
sequenziare il DNA
e scoprire che anche quello
si era incrociato con Homo Sapiens.
In realtà la nostra specie,
fino a relativamente poco tempo fa,
conviveva con altre due specie umane,
che erano queste due
e che hanno lasciato qualche traccia
nella nostra eredità genetica.
Tornando verso nord,
e spostandosi un pochino verso est
arriviamo in un luogo
che oggi è l'ultimo luogo
che ci può raccontare
com'era l'Europa prima della glaciazione,
prima di 20.000 anni fa:
la foresta di Bialowieza, in Polonia.
Queste sono ovviamente immagini di adesso,
e non immagini di 20.000 anni fa;
ma la foresta di Bialowieza
è l'ultimo lembo di foresta primaria
rimasto in Europa;
e anche l'ultima foresta
dove vivono in libertà, oggi,
i bisonti europei,
che probabilmente 20.000 anni fa
erano una delle prede fondamentali
di quelli che erano i nostri antenati.
E che sono praticamente scomparsi,
probabilmente per la caccia
da parte dell'uomo.
Scendendo ulteriormente,
arriviamo nel Caucaso:
ma qui facciamo un passo indietro,
perché non siamo più
nella storia di Homo Sapiens;
ma incrociamo un nodo cruciale
e fondamentale lo stesso,
perché 1.800.000 anni fa
un nostro antenato, Homo Georgicus,
o forse Homo Erectus,
ancora non si è capito
se siano la stessa specie
o due specie diverse,
era arrivato già nel Caucaso.
Dopodiché, si sarà riprodotto per un po',
avranno fatto dei piccoli insediamenti,
un po' come i vichinghi nel nord america,
ma non sono riusciti a rimanerci:
in realtà, tutta la popolazione
dell'Europa è Homo Sapiens.
Però a Dmanisi, in Georgia,
hanno trovato quattro crani,
quasi perfettamente conservati,
di questo straordinario ominide,
che già 1.800.000 anni fa
aveva cominciato a colonizzare l'Europa.
Se noi scendiamo ancora un pochino
arriviamo in Anatolia,
tornando indietro lungo la strada
percorsa delle antenate di mia madre.
Arriviamo in Anatolia, in Turchia,
nella parte meridionale,
quasi al confine con la Siria,
oggi teatro di guerre tremende,
e arriviamo a Göbekli Tepe.
Questo posto è il più antico
centro religioso -
probabilmente un centro
rituale - conosciuto,
e risale a circa 11.500 anni fa.
Ed è la prima testimonianza,
la più antica testimonianza
del fatto che l'uomo aveva cominciato
a diventare sedentario.
E probabilmente aveva cominciato
a diventare sedentario
proprio in quella stessa zona,
perché a poca distanza da lì
si è scoperto -
queste sono le iscrizioni,
assolutamente incomprensibili,
ancora non comprese, di Göbekli Tepe,
che è stata scoperta solo di recente -
poco lontano da lì, circa 10.500 anni fa,
poco prima che l'uomo
diventasse sedentario
si arriva all'agricoltura.
Lì si sono trovate le prime tracce
di domesticazione del frumento monococco,
e lì, probabilmente,
ha avuto inizio l'agricoltura,
che poi è quella che ha permesso
gli insediamenti stabili,
ha tolto il nomadismo,
fatto iniziare il neolitico,
come viene chiamato,
e quindi ha permesso
agli uomini dell'epoca
anche di cominciare ad avere qualche cosa
come un centro religioso
o comunque un centro per riti
di cui non conosciamo moltissimo.
Scendendo ulteriormente,
riavvolgendo il film della nostra storia,
arriviamo un pochino più giù,
dove c'è il puntino giallo:
questa è la grotta di Manoth, in Israele.
E qui ritorniamo a quella
che è quella piccola parte,
quella minima parte del DNA
dell'Uomo di Neanderthal
che sta nel mio DNA,
cioè quel due percento.
Probabilmente è qui, almeno così si dice,
che circa 55.000 anni fa si incontrarono
Homo Sapiens e Uomo di Neanderthal.
In questa grotta, in particolare,
ma anche in altre grotte
di questa zona del Medio Oriente
sono state trovate
testimonianze di convivenza,
o comunque di vita contemporanea
di Homo Sapiens e di Neanderthal.
Per cui sappiamo per certo
che in quella parte del Medio Oriente
Homo Sapiens e Neanderthal
vivevano insieme.
Non si sa se in pace o meno,
questo non è dato saperlo,
però vivevano insieme.
Ed è lì, con ogni probabilità,
che si sono incrociati
e che sono rimaste queste tracce
del DNA di Neanderthal nel nostro DNA.
Ora, scendendo più giù,
non ci sono particolari altre indicazioni
e tracce del viaggio di Homo Sapiens,
salvo il fatto che nella valle dell'Omo,
in particolare proprio nella regione
di Addis Abeba, nella regione etiopica,
è stato trovato quello che è, a oggi,
il più antico fossile
di Homo Sapiens conosciuto.
È la versione primitiva
di Homo Sapiens, di 200.000 anni fa.
Prima di cominciare la migrazione
Homo Sapiens è cambiato molto
anche in quella regione:
pare che avesse colonizzato,
in parte, l'Africa,
soprattutto l'Africa meridionale;
che abbia attraversato,
circa 100.000 anni fa,
un periodo abbastanza terribile,
probabilmente per ragioni climatiche.
Un momento in cui l'uomo
era stato sull'orlo dell'estinzione.
In realtà ha poi recuperato
la popolazione umana,
e intorno a 70.000 anni fa
ha ricominciato a migrare
proprio da questa zona.
Questa è la storia mia:
siamo ritornati alla fine del viaggio,
e siamo di nuovo al punto di partenza.
È la storia mia, ma probabilmente
è la storia di molti di voi.
Di molti europei quantomeno,
perché è molto probabile
che se vi faceste
la stessa analisi del DNA
avreste dei risultati molto simili.
Qui siamo ritornati al punto
di partenza, Addis Abeba,
e siamo ritornati a un punto
in cui, con il racconto
della mia semplicissima storia,
abbiamo ricostruito in qualche modo
una parte della storia dell'umanità.
Se volete saperne qualcosa di più,
sul progetto "Genographics",
genographic.nationalgeographic.com.
Grazie.
(Applausi)